so microphone is in the wild I talked
about microphone is a lot already so I
thought of changing the title to in the
vowel
usually it's called strive for fully
radicalized systems and one thing which
all of my talks have in common
are the first three questions I asked
the audience because you know I want to
get to know the audience and I want to
know who knows microphones knows what
this is all about just a few of you okay
we uses them in production
okay who gets to use them in production
okay cool
first things first for an Austrian
company based in Vienna called square
solutions we do a lot of technical
consultancy so for example micro
fountains I can service architectures we
do a lot of HL transformation this is
what I will not touch in this talk we
will do a lot of we do a lot of software
delivery so we provide high functional
and high efficient teams and we do a lot
of upskilling so which way to really
give the experiences we make in our
project so the outside world that's why
for example here to talk at conferences
this whole story started in 2014 there's
this great book building micro services
from semi-human who is now in in the
next room I saw so I'm quite surprised
that still so many people are here if
some human is speaking in another room
and some human did a great thing with
this poker because till then it was not
really clear what micro services are
about people I went to a lot of
conferences in this time and people
always ask me okay how big should a
micro service be what is the difference
between service-oriented architecture
with micro service architecture so it
was really unclear what is this whole
micro service thing about and this book
for me and I think for the whole
industry made it a little bit clearer
created a common understanding of the
term micro services what Sam Newman
actually said is micro services
and focused on one thing to be
autonomous right so this was the
definition same numeral about
micro-services so even the definition of
micro-services seems to be micro right
and at this time a lot of companies
started to build micro services we saw
pictures like this from Amazon or
Netflix and many more started to go into
this approach of building micro services
to be autonomous right this was the idea
this is why we did this so why did we
want to be autonomous roughly there are
six reasons six good reasons why we want
to have autonomous micro service
architectures the first one is the
obvious one we want to have independent
deployments right we want our services
to be independent deployable let's say
we just change one service this one
service should be deployable
independently there are still lots of
companies who say that they are building
micro services but they cannot
independently deploy the services they
have this kind of monolithic deployment
where they deploy all the services at
once
this is not micro services this is
distributed monolids right and this is a
big big problem because this comes with
the disadvantages of monoliths and
councils the disadvantages of micro
services just in one architecture so if
you go from micro service architecture
you have to be able to independent
deploy things the second one is distinct
operation so each service runs on its
own so has persistence on its own starts
on its own dies on its own restarts on
its own right so it's fully autonomous
in its runtime the certain is that we
can be technology agnostic we can we
don't have to but usually it's a very
good thing that we can build services
this is very loud here that we can build
services in frameworks and technologies
that fits the problem best that's that's
a very good thing we go out from micro
services the fourth one is that we have
small interface services so usually the
amount of api's we expose from a micro
service api is quite limited you just
give a very very exclusive amount of
api's and publish it to the outside
world
we can model around business domains I
will not go into detail about the whole
blue book thing and whole domain driven
design thing but of course this is one
of the advantages we got there and we
can parallel development we can do we
can paralyze the road and sorry and this
is important because software eats the
world right we are building tons of
software we need to paralyze this stuff
so these are roughly the six reasons why
we do micro services and this is why
they do this blueprint architecture
looks somehow like this right micro
service architectures everywhere
we build new projects whose micro
services we started microwave monoliths
- micro services and beyond those micro
service architectures we usually have
something like this we have a single
page application this one can be written
in angle of you react whatever you
prefer
and in between we have a gateway which
connects those micro services with our
single page applications and there's a
first disclaimer here now okay in 80% of
the use cases that's fine okay in 80% of
the use cases disproving the
architecture works totally fine for the
rest for the rest of the 24 percent I
will I will tell you how we could maybe
improve the situation because why did I
tell you all this micro service
information or why did they give you
this introduction to my groceries and I
guess we had any cilantro most of you
know micro sources and know the
advantages of micro services but if we
now consider the single page application
and again take a look at those six
points I mentioned earlier we will see
that we have huge issues here on the
front inside of our application on the
front inside of our high tech chure so
we don't have independent deployments we
can't just deploy the whole single page
application or we can deploy nothing
right so it's binary one or CLR deployed
or not deployed
of course we can work with feature
talkers we can do all the things but we
do not fulfill these very important
characteristics of independent
deployments on the front inside we don't
have to sync operations so if something
breaks on the front inside the chances
are high that our whole front
we cannot be technology agnostic I was
the biggest because Angela conference
2014 and she can't in Paris and there
was a huge advocate for Angela back then
and I was really looking forward to this
conference and the first thing I hear at
the keynote was ego-mind I going to the
stage and saying okay
angularjs will not be supported any more
in the future and this is the first time
when I said okay maybe being technology
agnostic will also be trade in the front
end because we still have to fight with
this decision that we have a lot of
legacy angularjs applications which we
cannot migrate to angular there's still
not a real good migration path from this
whole big legacy angularjs applications
to the newer version of angular 2 maybe
a different framework so beam technology
agnostic could be also important in the
front-end we do not have those small
interface services as we have this
monolithic on front ends we can not
support parallel development that's the
most important point this is when people
usually come to us and say hey David we
have now six developers working on our
front end we cannot scale this up
they're stepping on each other toes we
cannot put more developers into those
teams so we don't have the possibility
to really paralyze this front-end
development this is usually when the
paint starts and this is usually where
people say okay from terminal it is born
right and as we usually do with
front-end monolids or with monoliths in
general we'll kill them with something
that starts with micro and in this
situation we kill it miss micro front
ends and this is all you usually hear
about and say okay we split our
front-end application into smaller
chunks into smaller single page
applications and that's it
these are micro fountains so I made it
in 20 minutes 10 minutes actually
and this is really the thing this is
where many many talks about microphones
already and again to tell you then okay
you can do this in Angola and you can do
this in future isn't this you could do
in indirect and this you could do in a
framework of the months but that's not
about microphone that's right the
interesting question which appears here
is how do you split those microphones up
right how do you do this where do you
find the right boundaries and this is
very similar to microservices where we
had the same problems in the beginning
where we didn't know how to slice them
how big they should be because we asked
the wrong questions so the question is
how do we slice those micro fountains
into two right panels and it turns out
that they have caused multi
possibilities to do this the first one
the most obvious one is that we say okay
we do really fully enter in vertical
ization
so let's consider this Amazon domain or
this ecommerce domain where we say okay
we have a catalog with ordering and we
have a profile so catalog shows all the
products right all our ring shows you
the current orderings and you can
process orders there and the profile
allows you to change your name your
profile picture you address all those
things right and then we say okay looks
good looks like three totally separate
bounded contexts maybe we just slice
them like this and we just connected by
hyperlinks this is a very easy product
right to slice our application to
smaller chunks and one application which
is doing this actually extremely good in
my opinion is Amazon right so the same
domain and you see on the left hand side
the product details page on the right
hand side you see the ordering page so
it's in German but I still think it is
it's visible and the interesting thing
about Amazon is if you hit the search
page for the first time and if you
finish the ordering you actually go
through seven different applications you
go through seven different applications
that they look totally different from
time to time you see it on the UI
elements you see it even off the fonts
you see it on the hair those are total
different that there's a to total
different header
and you sometimes even see them the logo
they use different logos on different
applications because they just say okay
we cutted it into smaller applications
and we just connect them by hyperlinks
it's the easiest thing you can do this
kind of hyper link connected
applications and if we take a look again
at advantages we say okay we now have
independent deployments I can deploy the
profile result deploying your ordering
we have testing the operation is the
profile fails the ordering will still
work we can be technology agnostic as I
said we can build this one in reacting
this one in angular we have small
interface surfaces so we just have a
hyperlink that's the smallest interface
surface you can get right it's that the
highest decoupling you can achieve in
the web development
you can model run business domain and we
support parallel developments are all
done right but this assumption is warm
one basic flow right it's based on the
idea that we have fully verticalized
systems and everyone who is working I
don't know more than 24 hours in in soft
engineering knows that's usually not the
case right we have some cross
dependencies between those services in a
very very good example for those cross
dependencies is usually the - right
because dashboards love to Sprague
service boundaries that's that that's a
favorite hobby and if you take a look at
this for example the dashboard maybe
wants to show the latest products wants
to show your current orderings and wants
to show your profile information right
it's quite it's quite natural I would
say and if we do this we have two main
problems the first moves over fetching
and the second one is over requesting
what does this mean so let's let's
assume ever there spot and it shows good
morning or good afternoon David Lightner
so we need the first name at the second
name and we fetch the first time at the
second layer from the user macro service
and the user micro service returns as a
profile with four two fields right we
use two of them first name last name
maybe it pretends as a chamber maybe to
do some kind of address and some kind of
other user information so we get 40
fields back use two of them so we are
fetch thirty-eight fields and if you do
this at scale
becomes a huge problem in future
architectures because we do a lot of
over fetching over fetching over
fetching
because we have very generic domain
services in the background but we have a
very consumer-driven APR of course in
the front end the second one even versus
over requesting so let's assume you want
to show the latest order rings on the
dashboard so the latest three orderings
so you fetch the latest orderings you
get three of them you want to show maybe
some product information to their
ordering so you take the Product ID from
the ordering and fetch the product
information from the product services so
you do three requests to the product
service for each ordering and then maybe
you want to see the delivery status so
you fetch based on the ordering ID the
delivery status right so you have seven
requests to just show the three latest
orderings and this is what we usually
tend to call or requesting and these are
both very huge problems in pic
applications which make them very
improvement and people start to blame
them restful api is mainly for for this
kind of situation but that's not a fault
of rest api it's just wrong usage of
rest api is right because rest eps were
made to provide generic api's they are
not made to provide consumers with my
api as we would need them here so we
could of course start to implement here
some kind of extra api extra endpoint
for the dashboard that this usually
results in a lot of orphan endpoints and
a lot of supplication the endpoints is
it's hard to maintain those services so
another approach or maybe better
approach which we usually tend to follow
them a so called
back-end for front-end so each front-end
has its own micro service which actually
does exactly the aggregation as we saw
before so the aggregation is not
happening on the client side anymore the
creation is done on the backend for
front-end so if the dashboard for
example needs is informational the
aggregation is done exactly by this
back-end for fronting and tell two
important things we we observe in the
world about packing for fountains the
first one is if you think very effective
software engineering I would say there
are four layers right so we have some
data layer with some persistence
we fetch data and we receive data then
we have some kind of domain logic where
we say okay I don't know if this person
is older than 18 years it can we can
order some kind of special products and
then we have some kind of process flow
if this service says a we go to this
service if this service B we go to this
service so based on the process flow we
can fulfill some some kind of user flow
through our application then we have the
presentation logic where it's all about
bringing data into the right shape so
that we can visualize it on the front
end and it's very very important it's
really very important to understand that
the backend forefront and is just about
this presentation layer right so you
should not put any kind of domain logic
or process logic into there why because
otherwise you will end up again in the
application because this back-end for
funders are just used by this front-end
they are just here to transform generic
domain service api's into consumer
driven api step that's their job it's
really just shuffling data around
aggregating data and bringing in
bringing it into the right into the
right shape and the second important
thing to understand is that the packet
from front end and the front end itself
are warm deployable unit even if they
run on different sisters because you're
not going to client the other one runs
on the server they are warm deployable
unit and we see very often in the right
now that people start to split this up
people say ok Java developers to this
JavaScript developers to this but then
you lose most of the benefit right
because the idea is here that if I need
here special API I just say ok let's go
there edit here let's fetch the data and
we're done right you should never split
those two things up this is one thing
it's just part of the front and on the
backhand side it's like a port on the
back end so that we can avoid our
requesting you know over fetching
another thing we see quite often these
days is that people start to use
graphical instead of packing for phonons
which is in our point of view quite
quite good approach because graphically
allows you just to do presentation so
it's it's very opinionated it's very
hard to put process flow and domain
logic into craftwell so this is why why
we see
it's a good idea to use craft column on
this side of the application and this is
how we can solve these issues of over
requesting and over fetching when it
comes to hyperlink in the created
applications but there's always a path
right and if you here but you know okay
everything you're here to file was
useless it's not like this but of course
I mean it's it's obvious right hyperlink
integration practice in your page
application that's that's clear you go
to the server and you have all this
round tip so you you lose this flow and
flow of angle off of a few chairs no
react whatever uses single page
application frame the idea of single
page applications is not to go to the
server and to follow each hyperlink and
to chunk from application to application
but it's about providing a flow and flow
for the users so this of course breaks
the hyperlink integration the second
problem is that we introduced a
horizontal a and this is a very
important in my opinion because if you
take a look at this few aggregation
layer it's a horizontal layer in our
architecture right and we wanted
actually when we started to build
microservice our goal was to go away
from this horizontal layers because they
have found important downside if you
want to change something here you need
to change it here and you need to change
it here that's what we call the ripple
effect right this is why we started to
verticalized our systems that's why we
started we shouldn't separate based on
technical concerns we should separate
based on domains because we wanted to
avoid this ripple effect we have it back
and even worse we have this kind of
horizontal layer which will affect one
change with multiple results right so if
we change this service to change the
height that we need to change the
ordering and the dashpot service for
example and this is the problem of those
horizontal layers and we get them back
if we go for bacon for fountains of
course because we have one indirection
which tends to be horizontal and the
third thing is it only works on a very
coarse grained level so you can go for
hyperlink integration but it will just
work on average
Osment level right but everybody of us
is building applications as huge as
Amazon and and for smaller for smaller
chunks of Jerusalem they are possible to
really slice it up in a way how we
wouldn't read it for hyperlink
integration so maybe let's let's rethink
this whole body of micro Fontana let's
take a step back let's assume we could
we could do something like this we could
have a dashboard micro service which
provides the front and on its own so it
returns the front-end and then we have a
profile micro service which provides a
special view for the profile which can
be done for example and Pettit into the
dashboard and we have the same thing for
catalog and we have the same thing for
orderings so we have we have two
different definitions of micro services
we have this one micro service per page
approach where we just linked by
hyperlinks and we have this idea of
having multiple microphones get page and
and for me the second one is usually
their stuff I mean when I talk about my
performance the first one is just linked
applications but I'm not religious about
this term it's not it's not my intention
but this causes a lot of confusion for
example the inventor of Redux just said
he doesn't understand my good friends
yeah and I think this is basically
because we don't have a common
understanding what we're talking about
when we are talking about microphones
all right multiple people use
microphones but all use them differently
so so we have those two definitions we
have to warn where we say okay we just
link applications together and we have
another one where we say okay we have
really mountable
microphones and spare page so let's talk
a little bit about the second approach
this one here again the same question
how do we integrate them right how could
we integrate those different microphones
per page and and the next slide is I
think the most complex I ever created
yeah please stay with me I will try to
explain it as good as possible so let's
assume we have microphones we have three
of them so we have three repositories of
microphones
and the easiest thing we could do is we
just take all them and pummel them
together to build them we take those
three macro fondants model them together
to Vaughn deployment monolids deploy
this thing and then the client fetches
the whole application once it hits our
edge side services that's what we tend
to call build time integration so we
integrate those micro fondants together
at Build time another approach would be
server side integration where we have
again those three micro fondants we
built them independently we deploy them
independently and once the client hits
our edge side service we start to battle
those microphones together to one
application and provides the client this
this one application and the last
approach would be that we say okay we
again have three micro fountains we peel
them in the plane independently we
deploy them independently and the
clients can fetch them independently and
degree education standing the runtime
right so these are actually the three
options we have I don't say that one of
them is better or worse but these are
the three options we have so let's let's
talk about all them in detail a little
bit so bill time integration is
definitely the easiest one right this is
the easiest approach you could go for
you say okay we have those three
applications usually you to something
like putting them into one mono repo so
who knows what a monorail is if you okay
great so why do we do this why do we put
things into mono APIs basically for two
reasons it allows us extensive code
sharing and reuse so let's let's assume
we have a button and we want to use the
same partner in all our microphones so
we put all the microphones in one in one
repository we would we would put the
button library in the same repository
and we can easily share this button
between those microphones without the
version conflicts and that the burden of
distributing libraries so if you would
not go for a mono way put there we can
change the button we need to push the
button we need to go to all the
microphones and increase the version and
and get the latest version of the
problem so this is why we tend to use
one or a post there many companies used
in Google uses them for example Google
has one company more away for Facebook
has the same and
and other big companies but it's
important also to mention here that
those companies invest a lot in tooling
so it's not just that they have fun big
kids repo lying around somewhere so they
have a lot of property and unwritten
toolings for those mana rapists but if
we were not Google or Facebook we can
also use moderators their tools for
example in avail which tended to be more
angle of focus but these days it's a
monorail / tool to be technology
agnostic so you can also do it with
react Angela in common even so if you
want if you want to go this road and I
realize it is a good fit maybe if you
just say okay you anyway just use
angular you can use angle of workspaces
which provides you more we will teach
you out-of-the-box Mullis or you could
go with something which is called Liana
which is again a more complex way of
managing mana raper so you can even have
different versions of your libraries for
example we seen one mono repo and this
idea of mana repose is not new to
mention this again yeah for example if
you take a look at the Mozilla Mozilla
Firefox source code you will see that
this is a mono repo the whole Firefox is
bundled up into smaller modules so each
modules has its own folder in this mono
wrapper but the whole that the whole
application is in one repository right
even if different people are working on
different modules it's in one repository
and the big advantage is that they
always can ensure that if they change
something they will not break any
dependency because they just have one
version always and they are always on
the latest and greatest so this is the
advantage of mono reference that's why
we usually tend to do this when we do
build time in equation and if we take a
look at this now and began those six
advantages we now have independent
deployments still not right because we
cannot independently deploy one of those
microphones we can't just build them all
together but we cannot independently
deploy it
we don't have distinct operations so
usually this is this is can be an issue
here so if the father is problem there
the chances are highlighted everything
is problem we cannot be technology
agnostic but we support small interface
surfaces so as I mentioned we have
dedicated modules we have dedicated
front ends in our our repository this is
a real
dedicated and and autonomous
applications we can model around
business domains that the most important
part is we can support parallel
development so when we split our
application to small applications
smaller libraries by using for example
angle of workspaces this usually helps a
lot in paralyzing our front-end
applications but that's maybe not enough
for us so let's let's take a look at the
second option server side integration I
will share the slides anyway so you
don't need to take photos of of the
slides server side integration there are
a lot of projects I think the most the
most famous or the most Valmont one is
project mosaic from solando with its
Taylor does anybody know this year ok so
project Eila is build up on server side
includes and servers and includes are a
very old technique and they look like
this so you have in your HTML some kind
of includes and they are at server-side
so when you hit and when you fetch the
HTML they are resolved so in this
situation you would go to the product
micro service and would fetch the
products for you would go to the payment
payment for you and so on and so forth
and this service have includes or H that
includes these are two different
technologies which for actually the same
or fits the same purpose for this goal I
for example you spec here so here is
just building the application by
following this idea they just used
service I'll include and integrated all
together on the server side
Tayla from solando and many other
frameworks build up on these techniques
so it's it's really service ROH that
includes
under the hood but they of course
allowed to make this a little bit easier
and Taylor calls itself a layout server
so the idea is that you provide a layout
for each route where you can go to so
for example you hit the edge service you
say ok I want to see the dashboard then
the Taylor services ok let's let's try
to find a layout for the dashboard or we
have one right and then we have multiple
fragments in this dashboard we can see
this here so for example we fetch
head up from our header micro-service we
fetch the catalog for our catalog
microservice we fetched a calamari
account like a service and we really
fetch this from those micro services
right we do not do anything here we just
go okay they give me place on the the
HTML which I can include here's fragment
and Tangela comes with a few nice
goodies for example it has this primary
attribute where I can say okay the
catalog defines for example the HTTP
status code so if the that product is
not filed in the catalog and if if the
catalog returns 404 this whole page will
return 404 oh it has something like a
sink so when we don't get some account
information we say okay it's a sink so
we return the page without the account
information and we will load it
afterwards once we have it so Taylor
gives us this mechanism and it also
provides us fallback sources so let's
say this account fragment or this
account micro service is I don't know
build up on a legacy system and sometime
time down times from time to time so we
can just say ok we have a fallback
source so we go to some kind of static
static HTML and say ok the account
information is currently not available
but the rest of the application is
working so this is helping us in
building with sin and micro fountains
and of course you can you can then
define multiple templates for multiple
routes and this is how it's usually
working yeah the problem is taillights
that it's a little bit out of support in
my opinion there is not much moving in
this project but they could think that
there is a multiple other libraries
which which nearly works the same way
for example podium or open components
which which fulfill a single lecture the
owl based on this kind of architecture
that you aggregate on the server side
based on a specific route
goods then let's go into the last one No
let's go let's go back to the six left
points right so what do we have now we
have independent deployments right we
can deploy those microphones
independently if I change this Michael
front-end I can independently deploy it
is it as a huge thing with server-side
integration right
we have testing the operation so as we
saw with this fall back alright or with
this fall back source when this one is
failing we can still be resilient we can
return a front end we can say ok maybe
this part is not available but the front
end is not broken we can be technology
agnostic I did I didn't mention this but
for example project tailor has ways to
isolate JavaScript and also CSS so we
can really build those applications into
different technologies if we want do
this and we support small interface
surfaces again we can model around
business domains and we support parallel
development so this seems to be perfect
right well it nearly is we still have
this issue of long trips right we have a
lot of relatives because every time we
need to change something on the page we
need to go to the server and fetch a new
page so let's check the last one let's
check one time integration as we say it
at one time integration we've built
those micro focus independently we
deploy them independently it add the
browser see our interest area aggregated
right and we do this usually per
something which we tend to call
aggregation UI and this aggregation UI
provides us routing templates and lazy
loading so it's quite similar to what we
saw before on the server it's based on
roots and the based on rules we provide
templates and with these templates we
load micro fondants then and there is a
ton of frameworks actually which support
us in doing this and they are based upon
our frames this was all the frameworks
used by authorities everybody hates our
frames now so we tend to use web
components does everybody into web
components okay for those who don't know
them it's like iframes in cool I would
say yeah so they provide some kind of
similar isolation so you can actually
extend the Dom this your own elements
and they give you quite good isolation
like iframes and there are frameworks
which actually are build up or web
components or iframes like single espía
meter SP a root or a micro Fe and they
tend to call themself meta frameworks so
frameworks that allow
you to aggregate multiple frameworks and
I think may the framework isn't really
heavy we're out there so as I said a
metaphoric is a framework to handle
multiple frameworks right and this is
what those frameworks are called and to
be honest we also somehow guilty because
we did something similar in our company
we builded some kind of meta framework
also which allows us to aggregate
different micro font it's at runtime and
there's major frameworks as mentioned
they are doing one thing they are
aggregating the different fonts to
gether and in particular they do did you
have a few few core competencies right
and the first one is for example is like
isolation and Composition so it allows
us to isolate those different micro
front-ends and compose it together at
random the second one is routing so
based on the route we provide different
aggregation so as we saw on the server
side and the cert on is messaging and
shared States so usually you want to
have some kind of messaging between
those microphones on the server on the
client side so for example if somebody
wants to buy a product this must be
known by the ordering microphone so
these are usually the things which does
favor explain you and we were thinking
about this and we were a little bit of
unhappy of our current solution we said
ok let's let's let's rethink this let's
say ok we have those different fountains
and we want to aggregate them but we
don't want to have this mater framework
because we want don't want to have to
start at this vendor log tries right
because here you have a vendor log on
the media framework level and even on
the framework level so it's kind of kind
of kind of heavy kind of fat we didn't
want to have this so we thought about ok
how can we solve this how can we solve
this just by utilizing the web platform
and it turns out that the web platform
is quite mature when it comes to these
things so as relation composition has
said since since a few years we have no
web components they are now also
actually supported by most browsers and
there are polyfills for most other
browsers so we can support it on the
Internet Explorer 9 which which is most
of the cases
good enough
to us so we can say okay we can chose to
the isolation compositional about web
components right so we just use web
components to get to get this chopped
down the second thing is routing so how
do we achieve the routing who takes care
of the routing who takes care which web
components to load now and there's a
there's a nice library which we found
which is the Varden route I don't know
if you know about in also people nobody
and it was a huge it's still a huge
frame wagon in the Java world and it
switched a few years ago from give it
here to to web components so it
contributes a lot to the web component
and community and one thing the
contributed is a Ruta which is based on
web components and this one looks like
this so you just import your route or
say okay into this outlet I want to load
my router and then you define routes
what this looks like and react or
angular ruta and the thing is that you
define the route and based on this route
you load a web component so as I said
web components are just extensions of
the dome so they are just real did it
just you just you just look like like
like native components and then you say
okay based on this path we call a web
component and load it there yeah and
this is very important as a as a few
really nice features for example lazy
loading so it allows us to lazy load
bundles once we hit the special route so
if you go to user profile page we can
start a load the user profile bundle
which then provides the web component
for the user profile view so we said
okay let's go with this tiny small
library part in router for routing right
and then we at the last point messaging
in shared state so as I mentioned
usually you want to share state between
those microphones on the on the on the
runtime right because you say okay I
don't know you you add a product to the
cart so you need to to inform multiple
and multiple microphones that you
currently did this and there are
multiple approaches how you achieve this
so one is for example providing a global
Redux tour so one one pick Redux tour
where all microphones can access this
can be useful in most situations I think
it's it's an overkill
so what we tend to use here is we just
use normal streams so for example our
jet streams where we say okay we provide
the central streams but all our micro
fondants where people can subscribe and
publish messages or even more unwise
related we say okay each microphone tent
provides its own stream publishes
messages there and these dreams are
immutable so you cannot publish meshes
messages from the outset sorry you can't
just publish messages from the micro
front end so in this situation we have a
mutable stream and all our microphones
and if somebody else is interested in
the information of another micro front
and it just subscribes immutable stream
so you usually have those three options
some kind of global state management
like Redux and global event stream which
you can achieve physics chest or artists
immutable streams which are provided and
just for subscriptions from the
microphones and with this we just have
to really really small dependences which
is a which is a web component real-time
which is a nice chase library for for
streams and they allow us to actually
achieve all what we got before from Mike
and formative frameworks and if we think
about this now and it's a very
interesting sort in my opinion then this
index.html is becoming the environment
right so for example what is coupon it
is for our micro services is the
index.html for our microphones and all
we need to do then here is we say okay
all our microphones all they need to
provide is just a web component right so
if we add another microphone and it just
needs to add another web component we
can add it to the router and we can of
course or it can of course access our
shared States so that's that's our
contract a web component which we can
and easily integrate and then people ask
me okay where to put a framework here on
the environment or on a micro fountain
and this is a very very common question
we get and and I think it usually
depends on the framework which you're
using right if you for example go for
something like angular react or a few
chairs which are which are quite health
works usually would put them on the
platform you would say okay the
microphone can expect there's angle i8
available on the platform right now if
you say okay you don't want to have this
you want to be fully technology agnostic
then you usually go with different
frameworks you always with with micro
frameworks you go with very very small
things like Center like Mike's well
dissolve your stencil or sketches which
are just frameworks a very low
abstraction above web components which
which just have a very very tiny size
once they're compiled with a angular IV
maybe we can also move angular here up
to there but but for now in my opinion
it's too big to provide it with every
microphone that this will kill your
performance so if you go for for bigger
frameworks like like angle I said we
usually move it to the web platform to
the environment and if we go for really
tiny small frameworks where we say it's
important for us that every team can use
a different framework that we can really
stay decoupled there usually tends to go
with those those micro frameworks like
smelter stencil so these are these have
one thing in common they're actually
just web component compilers right we
just provide you a more neat way to
create web components and once you
compile and you have native web
components and you don't have much of an
overhead during runtime so our
environment is the index.html this is
very important and if our environment is
the index.html there is another very
very beautiful idea in my opinion which
is called immutable weapons anybody ever
heard of or immutable Web Apps
okay so immutable Web Apps
I inspired by 12 factorial who knows 12
X types
okay 12 fact I have so 12 rules to build
maintainable microservices so there's a
12 rules people came up to to say okay
this is how a microservices should look
like for example one rule is that the
environment should provide the
configuration so one rule one rule for
on the rule sorry or fill factor is the
environment is injected from the outside
by environment variables so your micro
services are not builded with some
of configuration to get it at one time
from the environment where they are
running and for example this idea of
providing environment variables is also
used in in web applications where we say
ok our environment is mentioned before
is the index.html so we define here an
object which is called M which provides
all the configurations at runtime so
once we build our microphone ensuite on
need to know anything we get this from
our environment we get this from our
index.html a second idea for example
from 12 factory pistols we that we
clearly define our dependencies we
clearly say okay we have a dependency of
on this service in this version and the
same thing is what we do fire mutable
web apps where we say okay we define
here exactly which by confronted
individuals movie want to use so we have
a list here of all the microphone ins we
currently use and you can easily adopt
them and update them by just going to
the environment and saying okay we use
now they use a profile macros
microphones and in version two instead
of version one and this is this is this
is immensely powerful following this
idea by understanding that the
index.html is the environment of micro
fountains if you go for one time
integration so let's let's go one last
time through the students points right
we have independent deployments we can
achieve this with some time integration
of course we have distinct operations as
we've seen we have the possibility with
web components to create some kind of
isolation that allows us to have
distinct operations we can be technology
agnostic it depends which framework you
use as I mentioned I would not use
futures and angle on the same page this
is just too heavy right you will kill
all your mobile users you usually don't
want to do this but you can you have
small interface services you can model
around business to mate and you can
support parallel development right so
again all the six advantages which one
to use now filter one time integration
I'll I give this I gave this
presentation a lot of clients and they
usually ask me ok that's all nice and
which one to use now right
and and the propose like cadenza that I
could then make it it really depends on
on what you try to achieve if you want
to go for a classical request/response
models where you say okay I do a request
and I get a few back as a response right
then of course service that in equation
is maybe the more natural fit and the
important thing about servers and
integrations that the integration the
interaction between those microphones is
done on the server side right so if they
need to share some kind of information
that's always done on the server side
but if you want to go for long layering
applications where you want to have this
flow and single page application feeling
of course you you need to go for runtime
integration and and that the big the big
differences here that they interaction
between those microphones as we saw is
usually done on the front and side so
there's some kind of shared oval state
there's some kind of of event bus or
some kind of stream right and this is
this is this is more the question where
you want to have the complexity of
integration and is it important for you
to have a fluent feeling oh it's um some
examples so as we saw this is for
example you speak here a lot bezel and
aveva group German company and runtime
integration I'm you you see a dozen for
example Spotify or Deutsche Bank so
there are companies doing both things it
has not bad our Everest case it really
depends on what you want to do and where
you actually want to have to complexity
and it's a question of usability and at
the end right so what did we see we saw
four different kinds of my performance
we saw the first thing which is called
hyperlink integration is a runtime
integration service silent equation and
runtime integration so it build them
integration service education from time
integration and then again as I said I
do this talk quite often their clients
in the day ask me
okay thanks yeah what what to use now
right you're not here to provide more
questions to you're here to to provide
answers and the
I think the first very important thing
in the and I tried to teach this
mysterious to this claim in the
beginning is to understand and I love
this definition of saying microservices
pious options right there's this
fantastic definition about microservice
which says micro-services buys
microservices pious options right and
the same thing is for microphone this
microphone inspire us options and the
bias that the options as we've seen why
the buyers independent deployment stick
provide us the option of distinct
operations to provide us being
technology agnostic to provide a small
interface services the providers to
model around business to mate and to
provide us parallel development but as I
said they allow us to buy options and
the important thing is not here options
the important thing here is you buy
because we buy these options with a lot
of complexity right that's the trade-off
we buy for example independent
deployments by using microphones with a
lot of complexity and this complexity
for example is uru existence II if you
go for microphones it's much harder to
achieve a consistent UI do X because you
have this kind of distributed
applications it's really hard to ensure
that everybody is using the same pattern
in the same font size but that's one of
the complexities you get or shared state
as you see before it's it's not easy
right to achieve something like shared
state on the total set this is very
complex you need to think a lot about
the synchronization how to restore those
states once the application is closed
and opened again resilience is a big
topic as in micro services resilience is
a huge thing how do you achieve a
resilience is the distributed fronting
application 20 and analytics is a big
challenge because currently you just
usually have one application which you
easily can trace but if you have
multiple components per page it's
getting hard to trace them and to the
right analytics often first if you want
to go for progressive web apps don't go
for micro fountains right these are
unsolved problems you cannot really go
in an offline first approach if you
build microphones and lots of lots of
more things so it's really of
buying options you can get all those
options or you can just take two of them
but it will cost you some complexity
it's always in training but let's assume
when you say ok we won't have
independent deployments that's very
important for us we want to have
parallel development right those are the
two things we want to have don't say ok
it's fine let's go then let's go with
microfinance then again the question
what which one to use no right I told
you already I want to buy these options
which one to use and it hurts I know it
hurts to say it is and it even hurts me
to say this but all I can really then do
is my favorite book right if somebody
asked me which which won't we use no
right because it really depends right if
it's so hard to say again and again but
it really depends right and it's super
important to understand and this is the
most important thing you should take off
this talk is that there is no silver
bullet when it comes to microphone isn't
there is no one size fits at all it's
all about mixing and matching right so
let's assume again that we have this
application with the landing page with
some kind of shop and with some kind of
authoring so 3 may be quite good
decoupled bounded contexts we could say
ok let's give it a first try let's go
with hyperlinks that's a it's a super
nice option let's say ok we start he was
hyperlinks now but maybe this shop is
still too complex for one team maybe you
still want to have some kind of
parallelization or resilience there then
you say ok let's split up the shop
further let's go here for runtime
integration because it's very important
right that the application still feels
fluent that the ordering process is very
important for our customers so we say ok
let's go for runtime integration there
and maybe the ordering is also still too
complex maybe it's too complex for one
team to handle this whole order process
and maybe we have to talk with a lot of
you know strange old systems and it's
kind of kinky stuff which usually need
to do with ordering so maybe we go here
for server-side integration because you
know it's it's not so important anymore
the customer already bought a product we
can have a couple of round trips now so
it's really about mixing and matching
right those options I showed you and
based on your problem based on your
application based on your domain based
on your problem you have at hand you
really need to find the right mix here I
cannot give you that the fulfilling
answer here maybe but really be creative
try to understand you domain try to
understand how you can cut your
application into smaller fountains and
there's one one one final secret I want
to share with you and maybe it seems to
be obvious but I think it's very
important to understand and this final
zinger is micro founders of distributed
systems who knows they want and the only
definition of distributed systems nobody
again it's important to understand first
of all that if you build micro fondants
you build distributed systems in the
front ok and they've one and only true
definition at least for me for
distributed systems is that everything
that can go wrong will go wrong right
and keep keep this in mind keep this in
mind and we see a lot of clients now
starting with micro folders from scratch
right and saying ok we will build this
with micro fondants now and we will
start immediately with going into a
microphones and a project this is
usually a destroyed a lot of pain so
maybe maybe if you if you create new
applications or if you think of going to
microphones on the project maybe start
with a monolithic first approach right
thank you I hope this was useful
[Applause]
any questions yes the question was if
global stars are a good thing right in a
more abstract way I would say should we
should we have some kind of global
styling where we define for example
default fonts and things like this well
I think what we currently do in in
front-end engineering and why we use all
the single page applications is because
we want to achieve component written
development right we do not we do not
build pages anymore we build smaller
components and aggregate them together
to choose huge applications that's what
we react that's what angular products on
the table and I think based on this idea
of component or even development this is
this whole idea of styling changed a lot
because back then we had separate
separation of concerns we said okay the
styling is in one file to HTML is
another file and for example a Java
Script is in another file but now that
in separation is a little bit different
in my opinion because the separation is
based on components and a component
itself should bring the style should
bring the Java Script should bring the
HTML so what we usually came to do if we
go for microphones there's actually a
big topic which I which I didn't even
open is of course some kind of Design
Systems and kind of component libraries
which are used and by different
microphones and which can allow us to
ensure that we have a consistent UI
Angelique's so we for example have a
container component which comes with
some the default font size which comes
with some kind of header information and
we have for example a button which comes
with some kind of styling so we do not
have any global CSS anymore because we
usually want to avoid this but there
companies would wear differently so for
example the the Gmail right Gmail had a
big redesign last year
all they did is they changed CSS because
they didn't touch anything of the HTML
and JavaScript they just changed the CSS
but I think this is more the oldest way
because it's not really there the
component driven way and usually you
have one component which comes with
styling and comes all those things so
you usually don't have at least not a
huge global CSS anymore
okay yeah yeah yeah they were platform
well no we don't use it we just provided
actually we don't use it in this layer
we just ensure that every every micro
front-end which is provided can ensure
that there is an angular instance on
this application do you know what I mean
we just dip we just provide the
dependents you want because you could
also say okay each microphone encounters
its own angular version but this is
usually from from a form application
size a big problem so that's why we
provided once and every bias is okay I
can I can be sure that there's angle I
available at runtime from you exactly
[Music]
it's one single page application so they
share one angular framework to share one
index.html so it's really it's really
one instance which is running all the
time it may be you lazy loads and some
microphones but it's still on volun
since always one that states about one
time integration it's really like SP
just just with separate wrapping points
in our case okay if you have any further
questions reach out for me by email or
i'm here i think i'm tomorrow and friday
so we can also have a chat during lunch
items like this
cool thanks
you